Hoy se celebra el Día Internacional de
la zamba popularmente conocida en Brasil
este ritmo que llegó a las ciudades a
finales del siglo 19 y adquirió
popularidad internacional entre 1920 y
1930 tiene su origen en bailes y
rituales africanos saludamos entonces a
nuestro segundo invitado el día él es
Anderson baltar periodista de radio
Arqui bancada radio dedicada al carnaval
y la zamba Anderson gracias por su
tiempo por estar con nosotros esta
mañana de viernes en directo América de
France 24 y precisamente hoy viernes que
podemos ir a bailar sama no este fin de
semana y le pregunto Cuál es el origen
de la Samba como ritmo además A cómo se
compone y las características de este
ritmo musical
Buenos días un placer
la Samba
de varios rituales
que vinieron de África con Los Esclavos
Y que
todos aquí en la Bahía encontraron un
formato
en Río de Janeiro
en la década de los 20 del siglo pasado
y Incluso en la región central de la
ciudad donde se concentraba esa
población
voy a recordar que los esclavos habían
sido liberados hacía poco más de 30 años
era una población bastante
marginada
era perseguida
y la zamba era la forma principal que
tenían para expresarse esas personas
entonces
gracias a la Samba y a su reconocimiento
a lo largo de las décadas sobre todo a
partir de los años 30 y 40
hasta la dictadura de de Vargas
fue un producto de exportación de música
de la música brasileña por excelencia
nosotros conversamos sobre esta
integración el crecimiento de las
escuelas de samba las zamba se ha
transformado en un producto cultural
multimedia entonces claro
básicamente esa formación a partir de
los años 30 y 40
como una grande
expresión de la cultura brasileña
Anderson también por supuesto como a
todo el mundo le afectó el covid 19 a la
zamba a a digamos a seguir expresando
ese sobre todo en las calles desde la
ciudad de Río de Janeiro el famoso
Carnaval mundialmente conocido de Río
Entonces cómo el covid 19 afectó a esta
manifestación artística tan importante y
además a como salieron a flote
nuevamente tras la pandemia
Fue bastante complicado Raúl la gente
pasó dos años bastante duros
la por la primera vez en la historia no
hubo carnaval en las escuelas de samba
en 2021
mi escuela de samba y el carnaval de la
calle en ese año que era muy importante
aquí que es en Río de Janeiro y en el
2022 la gente consiguió hacer los
desfiles fuera de la época en el mes de
abril
pero nosotros tuvimos
una pérdida de millones de personas de
las escuelas de miles que amaban el
carnaval que desfilaban grandes
personalidades de este mundo de las de
la Samba por culpa de la pandemia una
dificultad muy grande
por la supervivencia de para la
supervivencia de estas gente que trabaja
en el carnaval es una industria aquí en
Río de Janeiro el carnaval da empleo a
personas Durante un año entero en la
ciudad a final de cuentas para hacer un
desfile de las escuelas de samba existen
personas que pasan meses trabajando
haciendo fantasías entonces
la escuela de samba prácticamente no
para tiene actividad del año entero
nosotros tenemos ahí miles de personas
trabajando en el carnaval que dependen
del carnaval incluso incluso yo con
tengo un medio periodístico
especializado y ahora en el 2023 se
espera la vuelta a la normalidad se está
buscando una preparación para el
carnaval dentro de la normalidad y que
las escuelas hagan sus eventos
un local de samba la ciudad sí Tuvo una
un movimiento bien grande el significado
Anderson de la zamba para la cultura en
Brasil No qué tan importante esta
manifestación artística para todos los
brasileros
la Samba es un
yo despecho que hablar tengo respeto es
lo que me yo es lo que mejor sintetiza
lo que es la cultura brasileña a partir
del momento en el que la Samba es muy
inclusiva tiene unos pasos de cualquier
para cualquier persona cualquier clase
social cualquier región llega y es bien
recibida se integra participa
yo creo que la Samba tiene un factor
comunitario muy fuerte
que une personas en torno a un ideal a
un desfile a una presentación
algunas veces he oído que bueno lo
considero la mayor verdad en las
escuelas de samba de Río de Janeiro
la competición de barrios más famosa del
mundo porque las escuelas están allí
comunidades
envueltadas de pequeñas comunidades
barrios y babelas la periferia de la de
la ciudad
es un espacio donde esas poblaciones que
durante el año son invisibilizadas allí
Ellas tienen su espacio y Brasil se
muestra también el y Brasil se
Identifica las historias de nuestra
cultura son contadas en estos delfiles Y
eso es muy importante Anderson cuál
sería a su parecer la Samba o una de las
zambas más famosas no y cuántos tipos de
de samba hay dentro de todo el género
musical Hay diversidad digamos
mucha mucha diversidad como en el rock
como estos géneros fusionados de la
Samba También tenemos la Samba que se
canta en las escuelas las ama más
tradicional
Samba de raíz
tenemos algo más moderno que es el
parque la voz a Nova
que tuvo más éxito a partir de los años
50 con Tom
ahora vamos pero decir cuál es la más
famosa es muy complicado a veces
es un mundo muy complejo y todo el mundo
escucha este tipo de música pero yo no
no me hagan cantar por favor
pero yo creo que la Samba más famosa
aquí
que mejore explica Brasil
es la sama de pandero por lo personal es
una coincidencia muy feliz la selección
brasileña juega
y todo el mundo en la escuela de en el
mundo de samba está muy
emocionada por el juego por el partido
pero mañana vamos a tener el tren de
samba
un evento tradicional
donde la gente ocupa un tren
de un barrio muy tradicional y también
allí las escuelas desarmaban hacer mini
desfiles claro el sábado y el domingo
y van a hacer ciertas alegorías y en fin
Río de Janeiro tiene fiesta y vamos a
esperar que Brasil gane vamos a celebrar
la vida que es lo más importante Así es
celebrar la vida y Anderson Bueno nada
ojalá que nos veamos el año que viene en
el carnaval de Río un abrazo gracias por
estar con nosotros en directo América
te esperamos aquí Les esperamos a todos